hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
book one of cicero's on the ends
torquatus is presenting the epicurean
position on ethics and one of the key
distinctions that Epicureans made was
between bodily and mental pleasures and
pains this is part of what distinguished
them from other schools of hedonism
you'll notice in this work they talk
about the C Rene X and eros tipis that
was a school that held that mental
pleasures and pains were less important
or perhaps just the same as physical
pleasures the Epicureans placed a great
stress on mental pleasures and pains and
there's a few things to say before going
into their actual doctrine as we find it
in this text one of these is that the
Epicureans like some of the other
philosophers of their time were
materialists so strictly speaking all
that that exists are atoms and bodies
well there's the void as well but
everything that exists is really
corporeal so if they were here in the
present day mental pleasures and pains
they would say these are connected with
our brain there's nothing mysterious
about these other than the fact that we
don't quite have an explanation for how
all of that takes place at this point
but they do think that you can still
make some sort of distinction between
corporeal pleasures like the pleasures
of drinking a bit of coffee or you know
feeling a nice sensation on your skin
say when you take a shower or any other
thing like that and then what they're
calling mental or in in the Greek
psychical pleasures those pleasures of
the soul now they don't think that the
soul is any sort of immaterial thing
that floats around all by itself there's
no dualism here but they are
establishing a distinction so torquatus
is going to tell us that mental
pleasures and pains derived from bodily
pleasures and pains he says a little bit
later
arise from or at or you know they have
their origin in the body and they're
based on or they can be referred back to
is another way of translating it
sensations of the body so when we talk
about mental pleasures let's take an
example that might be quite helpful when
you are say drinking a fine wine
now wine connoisseurs tell us that
there's all sorts of things involved in
it and there's like procedures we have
to go through so we can have the wine
breathe and all that and just put that
aside for a moment to think about the
way that you taste a wine and the
complexity of the taste on your palate
some of that is purely bodily in the way
that at the Koreans would would refer to
it here and certainly the act of
drinking is something bodily there's an
effect on your tongue actually a lot of
different things going on it's quite
complex there's mouthfeel there's the
the alcohol and what that is doing
there's all these different receptors
within your tongue and in your mouth and
there's the odor that's going up into
your your sinuses and nostrils all of
that is involved and you've got some
physical sensations there now think
about when you're drinking that wine and
you're comparing it to the wine that you
just drank and you're saying this is
much better I like the taste of this
it's got these different notes or
qualities to it that this was lacking
over here you're starting to move into
the realm of mental pleasures there's a
richer that you could call it manifold
involved there that the fact that we are
not just bodily but mental beings beings
that have this incredible mind that can
sort of reach into our you might call it
the source or treasure-house of
sensations and pluck all these other
things out that is the the realm of the
mental so mental pleasures arise from
the body there
based on what's going on with sensation
but in some respect they take us beyond
mere sensation of the present and this
is where we get to a very important
point for Epicureans mental pleasures
and pains not all of them but many of
them are in fact more intense than
merely bodily pleasures and pains now
you might say well how can that be
they're arising from the bodily
sensations how can there be this surplus
this value-added there well it has to do
for the Epicureans with time with
temporality with the kind of beings that
we are that have not just merely a
present but also a past and a future so
to take that example of comparing the
wine that you just drank with the wine
that you're currently drinking now and
enjoying more you're referring not just
to sensations that you're having in the
present through your body you're
referring to sensations that you might
say you've stored up in your mind and
you're comparing the two of them which
is a mental act and that is indeed as he
says more pleasurable so he gives you
some you know interesting discussion of
that here he says the body can feel only
what is present to it at the moment
whereas the mind is cognizant of the
past and the future and he gives you
some interesting things to think about
some some not quite case studies let's
call them general examples he says
granting that pain of body is equally
painful our sensation of pain can be
enormous Lee increased by our belief
that some evil of unlimited magnitude
and duration threatens to befall us
Hereafter
so you know for example you sprained
your ankle and you know it that hurts
but you get up and you walk on it and
you're like oh this this sucks maybe
I'll put an ace bandage around it to
stabilize it and then you realize that
this is the 20th time you've sprained
that ankle and each time that you do it
it keeps gay
worse and you think to yourself about
the fact that as you age your ankles are
gonna become weaker and you imagine the
pains that are likely to befall you
should you keep twisting and spraining
your ankle year after year after year no
there's there's no you know requirement
that you do this of course right but
this is what people in fact often do
they feel a pain and then that leads
them to thinking about other pains pains
that haven't even taken place yet or
pains that are no longer there for their
bodies but are still there for their
mind and that can be much more intense
he also says the same consideration may
be transferred to pleasures a pleasure
is greater if not accompanied by any
apprehension of evil so you think to
yourself about you know enjoying a
pleasure at the moment and the fact that
you're going to keep on getting to enjoy
it and nothing bad is gonna happen to
you as a result that's very different
than a stolen pleasure where you do
something and you're like oh man I hope
I don't get caught
alright that hope I don't get caught is
a mental pain and it's diminishing the
amount of pleasure involved in that case
you could also use another example that
he doesn't bring up here similar to the
pain one where you would say I'm
enjoying this pleasure now and this is
just a foretaste of how good it's gonna
be think about what is going on when
you're infatuated with somebody and you
first kiss that right and then you could
you might not actually be thinking about
much of anything you couldn't be
thinking about the kisses yet to come
and how great it's gonna be when you
move to higher and higher levels within
your relationship right and that would
be more intense pleasure you're
anticipating a future so this is very
important for the Epicureans they also
point out the fact that we have some
degree of control at least if we're
normally functioning over our
anticipations or expectations those are
the future
and over our memories that's the past
the things that we carry with us were
the things that we project ahead of us
we can manage them and so torquatus just
so he touches on this he says just as
we're elated by the anticipation of good
things we're delighted by their
recollection this is the way that we can
give ourselves greater mental pleasures
and he says fools are tormented by the
memory of former evils fools imprudent
people people who don't have the virtue
of wisdom think about bad things that
happen in the past that hurt them that
made them sad that caused them fear or
that disturbed them in some other way
and in doing so they're in a certain way
reliving it
sometimes more vividly you know if you
think about people who struggle with
deep-set trauma that they keep on going
back to over and over and over again or
people who got slighted by somebody the
person insulted them once and may have
forgotten the insults or may not even
have been cognizant of insulting them
and now suddenly they play it over in
their mind the rest of the day those are
mental pains and they don't actually
have to be feeling those so where Cuates
goes on he says wise people have the
delight of renewing in grateful
remembrance the blessings of the past
they can dwell on the things that were
positive and some of this would have to
do with how we choose to look at things
how we choose to distinguish between
what was good and what was bad or how we
frame things to ourself so a wise person
might look at the same exchange in which
some insult took place and overlook the
insult and think about all the other
pleasant parts of the exchange and not
allow that to ruin their day and when
they do that they are engaging in a
practice that produces mental pleasures
for themselves they went through exactly
the same thing as the foolish person but
they look at it in a different way they
choose to use your mind differently and
they feel pleasure as a result
so he says we have the power to both
obliterate our misfortunes in an almost
perpetual forgetfulness and to summon up
pleasant and agreeable memories when we
fix our mental vision closely on events
of the past then sorrow or gladness
ensues according as these were evil or
good so if we see ourselves starting to
get affected by something in the past
the Epicureans would say if it's
negative forget about it don't think
about that unless there's some sort of
usefulness in thinking about that past
case think about the pleasant things
instead or think about something else
and you'll feel pleasure
likewise when we're anticipating what's
ahead of us we have choices about what
we want to focus on and the wise person
realizes this and the fool doesn't this
is why Epicurus as torquatus tells us
has this famous passage where he says
living pleasantly living in such a way
that that gives you pleasures over pains
requires that you live wisely soppy
enter honorably enesta and justly you
step if you do not doing that then you
won't actually enjoy a life of full
pleasure and you will likely incur a lot
of pain if you're living imprudently
dishonorably and on justly you are
inevitably going to feel pains and these
are going to be mental pains and he
actually talks about in this place as
the Epicureans were want to mental
diseases when we have a physical disease
a physical disease gives us pain in some
way you know it could be something
chronic it could be something acute but
mental diseases also give us pain and
they lead to greater pain than most
physical diseases do physical diseases
are either going to get better or
they're not and after a while you become
accustomed to it but mental pains some
and stick with us for years and years
and years so he tells us what are these
mental pains here's some examples he
says a mind divided against itself and
filled with inward dis discord you know
disagreement with itself
a person who is perpetually swayed by
conflicting and incompatible counsels
and desires so this leads to things like
desires for riches Fame power
licentiousness eases also grief trouble
and sorrow which no art and consume it
with anxiety if men fail to realize the
mind feed feel no pain unconnected with
some pain of body presence or to come
and then what else death the fear of
death that people struggle with
he says superstition that poisons and
destroys all peace of mind these are all
examples of what torquatus is calling
mental diseases things that infect our
minds and lead us to have a you could
say unproportional or contradictory
relation to the vast array of pleasures
that are out there or that we can store
in here and they subject us to pains
instead so this distinction between
mental and bodily pleasures very
important from an epicurean point of
view they will give the priority most of
the time to mental pleasures
you